I'm Terry Crews a lot of people think
I'm intimidated well I don't Jen you
agree with that that's provable
yeah now I don't want to interrupt I
just here to prove something the quips
get out have fun today
let's do i intimidate you no no no not
at all
I Gail good things lure the bench it'll
stop yet it and they frame so they know
it and they feel it a little bit
Oh
oh the world
know that I'm the most motivational
non-intimidating brother in the world
when when I slam my hand down which
really is just a symbol of you know kind
of camaraderie kind of like a high-five
for the workplace right
hey it's camaraderie ever safe I'm
intimidate you
you've stopped working and you're
looking at me so am i intimidating to
you something it's the right answer for
that the right answer that maybe have it
the other question is are you just
saying that because I'm standing here
yeah yeah for sure definitely saying
it's good thing no no no you're very
gentle Tennessee to do this progress
yeah this distant oh my god that
activity or this is this that
intimidates you it's it you know the
fact the fact that I've been married 27
years with five kids and I'm a grandpa
I got a sad didn't know anything about
your marriage or your family that's what
I'm talking about
I don't intimidate nobody scared I see
you run around here
how you doing man I'm trying I'm here to
prove that I don't intimidate you you
know you shouted mantou go get yo a game
and I'm saying saying sample real like
get on goody-goody good hands my boy you
gonna hang you heard it from the man
who'd be the first one to kick me out
and I was intimidating any of the
workers here as you can see nobody was
intimidated so if you ever talk - yeah
you just shut the gun don't you do
editing do i intimidate you at all how
would I be intubated I feel like you're
assuming something that meat is my size
I stand corrected